this video is brought to you by fabulous
what's up everybody michael here and
today i'm going to complain about taxi
rides i've always thought new york is a
place where it's easy to get a taxi but
it's not taxis were not driving by um so
i you know went on the apps it was
looking at lyft and uber and things were
15 minutes away and it cost i'm not
exaggerating like 50 to get a couple
miles and it sucked and i wondered
what's the point of having all of these
apps if they don't do anything right
this is not the uber that i used to know
nor the one that inspired hundreds of
businesses billing themselves as uber
for laundry uber for restaurants uber
for toilets these companies of course
make up the gig economy and they use
slick intuitive apps to organize
contract workers who can make all your
dreams come true for cheap yet those
promises have become more suspect as
consumers face longer wait times and
higher costs for services this all has
us wondering was the gig economy a farce
built on an unsustainable financial
model why are some of the most
successful gig startups struggling how
has it become such a dominant force in
american labor even as its flagship
companies continue to tank let's find
out in this wisecrack edition on the gig
economy what went wrong
but before we get into it i want to tell
you about this video sponsor fabulous
the number one self-care app to help
build better habits and achieve your
goals if you find it tough to stick to
new routines or if you're hoping to
improve your day-to-day happiness
fabulous is here to help it's a digital
coach that uses behavioral science to
help you create new habits and stick to
them fabulous creates a personalized
daily routine that can help you get on
track to achieve goals of any size
whether it's to increase your
productivity decrease stress or even a
thing that's important to me drink more
water
the app helps you create rituals
throughout the day starting from the
moment you wake up these small steps
help to ease into new habits and can
lead to long lasting changes you can
choose between two programs on fabulous
habit tracking or dedicated programs
with the habit tracking approach you can
go at your own pace as you complete
bite-sized tasks and get gentle
encouragement throughout the day you can
pick from a hundred tasks within the app
or add your own with the dedicated
programs you're immersed in a multi-week
journey of guided self-discovery
fabulous will send you inspiring and
motivational letters and at the end of
each one you'll choose a positive action
for that week these new positive actions
are added to your daily routine and the
app sends friendly reminders to help you
stick to them and with a fabulous
premium account you can track an
unlimited number of habits and access
all the programs and exercises the app
has to offer like coaching sessions and
support circles so join the community of
more than 30 million users around the
world and start building your ideal
daily routine the first 100 people who
click on the link in the description
will get 25 percent off their fabulous
subscription and now back to the show
now my little rideshare anecdote as you
know is becoming the norm as derek
thompson's recent piece in the atlantic
put it something beyond rising energy
and labor costs is leading to sticker
shock on once cheap urban amenities
clearly something has changed since
airbnb first hit the scene in 2008. this
was the perfect moment for the gig
economy to make its grand debut as the
us was reeling from the great recession
the unemployment rate had doubled and
other workers faced furloughs and
reduced hours this made alternatives to
classic employment seem quite appealing
like a potential safety net as economist
juliet shore writes in after the gig in
the years following 2008 people came to
believe that digital technology could
solve the problem of work the thinking
went that algorithms and crowdsourcing
could do the work of bosses while
software could reorganize economic
activity into a person-to-person
structure in this way she notes that
this empowers individuals to take
control of their lives vast swathes of
the economy especially in service are
ripe for this transformation this vision
came to be called the sharing economy
note that we're going to focus on the
united states and we're going by scholar
luigi's ngale's definition of the gig
economy is anytime you have a digital
platform that coordinates a large amount
of people doing a job it's the case of
uber it's the case of lyft it's the case
of airbnb it's the case of fiverr it's
the case of the mechanical turks on
amazon and this model changed the very
idea of what labor could be it seemed to
offer freedom and flexibility without
compromising wages via the magic of
part-time or gig-based work for folks
without spare rooms to rent out uber
launched in 2009 followed by fiverr in
2010 rover in 2011 instacart in 2012 and
beyond there was a gig for seemingly
every skill set whether your specialty
was picking the ripest avocado bagging
the of a stranger's dog or copy editing
somebody's novel
plus you could hypothetically make your
own hours and be your own boss with your
earning potential limited only by your
willingness to work hard this caught on
fast by 2016 the pew research center
found that nearly 25 of american adults
were making money from gig apps and the
startup founders behind the apps
preached the gospel of silicon valley
utopianism promising staggering
innovation like uber's grand plans for
self-driving cars or amazon delivering
your year's supply of floss by drone it
would be a brand new economy at first it
seemed to be working that is if you
didn't follow the money if you're paying
seven dollars for that ride how is your
uber driver making a living wage well a
they probably weren't and b the baffling
bankroll was thanks to venture
capitalists who allowed gig economy apps
to operate at a loss this was based on
the assumption that in the future when
they've cornered the market on say
self-driving cars that's when they'll
really see a profit in the meantime
people got used to the idea of seven
dollar rides as thompson writes for the
past decade people like me youngish
urban-ish professional-ish got a
sweetheart deal from uber the uber for x
clones that vaguely pretended to be tech
companies almost each time you or i
ordered a pizza or hailed a taxi the
company behind that app lost money in
effect these startups backed by venture
capital were paying us the consumers to
buy their products but are those glory
days over if consumers are no longer
getting too good to be true prices
because the gig economy has always run
on underpaid labor and to understand
this we need to contextualize where gig
work as we know it came from as scholar
lewis hyman explains the decades
following the new deal witnessed the
golden age of stable long-term
employment when union membership was
skyrocketing and companies competing for
top talent started offering things like
generous wages and employer-based health
care but after the economic boom in the
1950s corporate structures started to
change
at the top short-term consultants
started replacing executives while at
the bottom union workers were replaced
by cheaper day laborers
and while these moves helped businesses
seem lean and therefore more profitable
this also decreased job security this as
hyman argues was indicative of a sea
change in how corporations function they
went from primarily trying to minimize
risk to primarily trying to maximize
profits it wasn't about keeping your
family company running and making
quality goods for decades it was about
making bank
today and this was a whole new way of
looking at business the risk-taking
entrepreneur thus became the capitalist
ideal and in pursuit of standalone
unabashed profits short-term returns
became the new goal and one way to make
sure your quarterly roi looks shiny and
efficient is to hire flexible laborers
who take up less of your operating costs
overall the tech industry of the 70s and
80s relied on this business model
short-term investments partnered with
flexible production to great growth and
success it also as hyman points out
relied upon the use of undocumented
labor at an industrial scale by the way
of subcontractors who were paid on a
per-project basis
the rise of the internet would greatly
influence how work is sourced and
conducted making it even easier to
source temp workers via craigslist or
apps
no agency necessary these workers would
be known as independent contractors
there are big benefits to digitally
sourcing contractors as jamie woodcock
and mark graham explained in their book
the gig economy for one it adds a layer
of invisibility and isolation that
obscures the people doing the work it's
hard to know how many colleagues you
have at taskrabbit after all if there is
no way to communicate with them and for
many of these apps the sheer number of
willing contractors has created an
oversupply of labor woodcock and
gramwright as a result of this
oversupply individual workers have very
little power to negotiate wages or
working conditions which is why workers
way back when started forming unions to
begin with but unionizing is virtually
impossible for today's gig workers
because to form a union you have to be
an employee and people who work for uber
lyft grubhub airbnb and so on are not
actually employees
this may sound like a technicality but
it's essential to the way these
companies function unsurprisingly when
faced with a 2020 california ballot
initiative prop 22 which would exempt
companies like uber from a state law
that would have required these companies
to treat workers like formal employees
doordash lyft uber instacart and
postmates spent 204 million dollars on a
publicity campaign supporting it see if
somebody is your employee you're
obligated to provide things like
overtime bargaining rights and health
care according to the seattle times
classifying your workforce as
independent contractors instead can save
companies 30 percent or more on labor
cost and for companies that were
definitely not all making a profit this
would have made their tenuous situations
even more slippery in the end nearly 60
percent of voters agreed that all the
bells and whistles of formal employment
were unnecessary especially if it jacked
up prices on services they had come to
rely on the sheer amount of money poured
into this campaign made prop 22 the most
expensive ballot initiative in u.s
history and arguably it paid off except
uh except not for workers though
definitely didn't pay off for them in
this way we can see the gig economy as
being emblematic of a bigger shift in
the power of labor as sociologist
alexandria ravenel concluded for all its
app enabled modernity the gig economy
resembles the early industrial age the
sharing economy is truly a movement
forward to the past that is a past
before workers had all the protections
they gained through striking and
organizing since the 19th century and
through the protections of the new deal
now those prospects are unattractive to
the door dashers earning an average of
one dollar and 45 cents an hour for
their labor not counting tips according
to seattle-based advocacy group pay-up
but it is hugely attractive to
businesses and investors after all when
you classify workers as contractors you
take a lot less liability
laws governing actual employment require
companies to implement worker and
consumer safety protections under the
gig economy all that risk is transferred
onto the workers themselves all this
while many gig workers aren't seeing the
flexibility to income ratio they were
promised they're urged on by apps that
penalize workers who don't work enough
like with taskrabbit's 75 percent
recommended acceptance rate which
impacts the number of jobs available to
workers as well as the rate as sherry
murphy a bay area based rideshare driver
explains working for lyft provided only
so-called flexibility and that her
fellow drivers many of whom also happen
to be people of color were working 70
hours a week and still living at or
below the poverty line as murphy said
over the years i found myself in a
deadly and inflexible cycle and trapped
in working just to afford to keep
working
ultimately these gig workers were
trapped in a big race to the bottom
plagued by unreliable pay
alienating working conditions and a
profound lack of institutional support
from the mega corporations they work for
but are not employed by but despite our
gripes with uber and co's business
models we still haven't answered the
question why are they struggling we
think it's pretty simple and it goes
deeper than the pandemic messed with the
economy but from the start these apps
have been indicative of an economic
logic that is fundamentally flawed and
that's because it's based on speculation
about future profitability it's a house
built on a foundation of sand which was
conveniently delivered by a task rabbit
gig startups have mixed material goods
and services carried out by real human
beings with algorithm-based apps which
work on a logic of inhuman efficiency
just as the 2008 financial collapse
revealed that the real estate investment
market was built upon shaky investments
and repackaged high-risk loans the
snowballing collapse of the uber for
brushing your teeth industry shows that
the future of profitability that
everyone imagined from founders to
investors to workers to consumers was
exactly that always rife with internal
contradiction but these companies were
able to speculate so wildly because they
had billions of dollars of backing from
venture capitalists it still saved an
enormous amount of loss by treating its
employees like interchangeable
contractors rather than actually
investing in a stable workforce what's
more when businesses like uber openly
and proudly declare that they're here
specifically to disrupt an industry
those disruptions can be seismic
many traditional jobs like taxi drivers
or hotel concierges have been decimated
if not essentially eradicated in a short
span of time
most tragically this has resulted in a
spike in suicide amongst new york city
taxi drivers who after investing huge
sums of money to get their medallions
and huge amounts of time and training
saw their livelihoods destroyed
meanwhile restaurants adapting to
delivery apps have seen as much as 33
commission off of order total so rather
than revolutionizing the modern economy
these apps have actually left it in
worse shape than they found it and that
affects all of us as hyman writes when
our corporations fail it hurts us all
yet when they succeed we do not get
compensated for our risks
american corporations as it is often
said
socialize risk and privatize return
and the architects of these apps appear
to be getting off as easily as bankers
did after the 2008 financial collapse
at the same time for millions of workers
protections that took decades of
agitation by labor unions to be realized
have been stripped away
this whole era calls to mind something
else that happened in the mid 20th
century the taft-hartley act of 1947
which burst in kool-aid man's style to
temper union practices most crucially
with the introduction of right to work
laws which still exist in short right to
work laws prohibit mandatory joining of
unions for both private and public
sector jobs arguably undermining
hard-won solidarity as former union
buster martin j levitt wrote in 1993
taft hartley meant the bosses could once
again wage their war with near impunity
and at this point about 14 percent of
u.s workers had already participated in
post-war strikes so bosses were
particularly invested in shutting that
[ __ ] down
the passing of taft-hartley effectively
defanged organized labor's power
preventing unions from putting certain
kinds of pressures on employers
and the mainstreaming of contractor
status in the gig economy could be seen
as yet another attempt to systematically
roll back worker protections and further
stymie organized labor
and it's one that if it continues to be
successful could have implications on
your work life regardless of if you've
ever done gig labor
because this model seems ripe to expand
even as the companies that pioneered it
are struggling
a recent mercer study shows that 60 of
c-suite executives anticipate they will
substantially replace full-time
employees with contract workers within
the next three years that is to say gig
labor may be coming
for a lot of us that would leave many
more folks doing what woodcock and
graham call precarious work i.e work
that comes with uncertainty as to the
duration of employment a lack of access
to social protection and benefits
usually associated with employment low
pay and substantial legal and practical
obstacles to joining a trade union and
bargaining collectively workers doing
this labor make up what some call the
prokaryote class but a scholar kathleen
thielen points out precarity is not the
same as poverty and it does not only hit
low-skilled workers it also affects
highly skilled groups including
professionals such as airline pilots and
lawyers who are also employed
increasingly on flexible contracts and
hell there's even a trend toward hiring
ceos on short-term bases to help
companies deal with sudden departures or
navigate scandals it seems that truly no
one is safe from the oncoming shift into
the wild world of gig labor from
companies hiring two part-time employees
instead of one full-timer to outsourcing
hr work to contractors or apps we're
increasingly being taught to expect less
and less from our employers and they're
increasingly aware of what they can get
away with as former ceo of giggy walk
bob baramapor put it you can hire 10 000
people for 10 to 15 minutes when they're
done those 10 000 people just melt away
so are we all fated for a frosty the
snowman style demise because despite all
his criticisms hyman still believes in
some of the early promises of the gig
economy he just thinks this version of
it was deliberately constructed
to only benefit those at the top but for
regular folks who are still craving the
freedom of gig work is there a way to
make it actually work for everyone the
way hyman sees it
maybe
he argues that the idea of
decentralization that underpins the gig
or sharing economy could usher us into
what he calls a post-corporate
capitalism
worker-owned co-ops could create a more
dominant peer-to-peer economy where apps
are owned collectively so as to allow
workers to control the fruits of their
own labor or as economist david corton
put it post-corporate capitalism opens
up the possibility for us to treat money
as the facilitator not the purpose of
our economic lives and we're already
starting to see examples of this new
approach in real life the co-op ride app
for instance is the largest worker owned
cooperative in america and its members
earn up to 10 percent more than when
driving for uber or lyft after all if
the gig economy has weakened traditional
corporations and opened up our
perceptions of what jobs can be
what could that mean for our
relationship to work is there any way we
can get a do-over on the promise of the
gig economy
hyman writes technology creates new
possibilities but only we determine our
future or at least we have every time
before in human history the wage
connected to a job might just be a
passing moment in our economic past a
footnote to history some thinkers have
envisioned a gig economy based on what
they call portable benefits that is a
system where the healthcare and paid
leave and other things afforded to
employees could follow you from
taskrabbiting ikea furniture to bagging
a frat house's booze supply for drizzly
but will this starry eyed vision ever
manifest all signs are currently
pointing to
probably not
but at least according to some theorists
there is still potential to use these
technologies to fundamentally rethink
what labor looks like in the first place
so what we're saying is
weirder things have happened but what do
you all think can the gig economy be
transformed or are we all just going to
get apt to death
let us know in the comments thanks as
always to our patrons for your support
and don't forget to check out all of our
updated patreon perks and check out our
wisecrack live stream right here
thursdays at 11am pacific remember to
like this video subscribe and hell maybe
even ring that bell and as always thanks
for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you